[Music]
danny is with us in st louis hi danny
how are you
hi i'm good how are you guys better than
we deserve what's up
hi so i was calling um because my
husband and i are looking for some
advice regarding transitioning our
mindset as we enter baby steps four
through six
okay
so for a little back ground so we got
married in august and we became debt
free in december
thank you
um since then we've finished baby step 3
and we've started our 15 um to our
retirement plan
but we're struggling with balancing
short-term goals like saving for larger
purchases
versus just living more freely and
starting to enjoy things more now that
we're debt-free
okay
you do have your 15 going into
retirement
and um
you are committed to finding some money
to throw at the house and get it paid
off and baby step six right
yeah we have a teeny tiny mortgage left
so and that's not a huge concern at this
point okay well i still want to finish
it off so it's still part of it baby
step six but
so your issue is just uh enjoying some
fun money
versus purchasing a car in two years
yeah so we've been so i'm 27 and i've
been driving the same car since i turned
16.
so i'm a little tired of it you need a
car um i need a car what's your
household income
um we make about 175. well you make a
lot of money then okay thank you yeah we
do well so when you when you lay out the
budget and you're having this discussion
with your new husband
um
you you
is there
too much money going on fun or not
enough money going on fun because you
ought to be able to buy a car out of 175
and still have a lot of fun
yeah i think it's more just that we're
we're balancing them both and we're
doing pretty good saving but i think we
thought it would happen faster because
of how much money we were able to put
towards our debt but now since we've
started like going on weekend trip i
mean we're not being reckless by any
means we're still working our budget and
everything it's just then like we'll
book that flight and then we'll be like
man that money could have gone towards a
car but we really want to enjoy things
too
because it's not an emergency i mean
while i'm tired of my car it runs and it
gets me to work every day
no this is a normal dilemma a lot of
people deal with because you've been so
gazelle intense and now it feels like
well we should be focused on the goals
having fun is not part of the deal but
remember you live like no one else so
that you can live like no one else and
so if i'm you i'm putting it in the
budget and then there's no guilt about
the trip because we budgeted for the
trip yeah that's the thing you're not
doing i think um let's step let's step
back at that a minute and go okay
if we
save if we
allocate
x number of dollars in the budget for
uh weekend travel
let's just give it a category okay
and
having done that we agree we're saving
a thousand dollars a month towards a car
i'm just making up a number two thousand
dollars towards the car whatever the
number is okay
um
and then you go and you spend what you
said you were gonna spend on weekend
travel not more
then there would be no pull
so that tells me you're not allocating
these things until after the fact
yeah i think i'm more tempted to be like
okay well let's see how little we can
live off of um yeah but i mean if you
put it down the budget you have that
discussion before the money leaves them
before the trip happens
okay
you and your husband are sitting and
looking at it on the paper and you're
going okay this is what we're spending
on this this is how i solved the problem
with my wife because she is a tight wide
and she would not spend money on herself
afterwards after we got through went
through all that hell bankruptcy and
everything and we had no trouble
allocating clothing money
for the family but she would spend a
hundred percent of it on the kids and be
scared of o'hara i'll just wear the
drapes
you know
and uh which is a bunch of crap and so
finally i had we had to break it out to
where we had a separate
envelope for sharon's clothes
to make her spend money on herself on
sharon's clothes
and uh that kind of helped her almost
heal
from this tight-fisted
trauma that we had been through right
that causes your fist to be so tight and
so we went from intense to intentional
and said uh okay this money the money in
this envelope it says sharon's clothes
cannot be spent on anything except for
sharon's clothes
and you know what you wanna know what's
weird we still have that envelope
that's weird i just thought of that
that's weird wow we should stop that she
has plenty of clothes but um oh my gosh
but i mean the point was that what
exactly what you're experiencing
was uh you know you're going okay i want
to be more mature but i also want to
have fun
i mean you know while we're going on
this trip we should not do that we
should just still be gazelle intense and
and but if you lay it out and you and
you put it a name on it and you say this
money is to be spent on weekend travel
it can't be spent on your car it's
already spent it's not it's spent on
paper it's gone
like insurance closed the money's gone
you can't spend it on anything else it's
already been labeled insurance closing
disassociate yourself emotionally and
say hey this two thousand dollars for
the weekend trip this is not car money
so we're not going to see it as money
that could go towards the car and when
it's part of the this is a great
discussion by the way and
and when it's part of the overall budget
you say okay that means we're putting
i'm
making up whatever number it is you can
make up whatever you want danny but two
thousand dollars a month on the car okay
and so i'm still gonna get the car at
christmas
i'm still gonna get the 15 000 car at
christmas i mean still gonna get it and
so i'm i'm it's not knocking me off of a
reasonable goal now yes i could get the
car in august instead of december by
doing no travel but we're making the
adult decision to be intentional and say
we're doing some weekend trips make 175
thousand dollars
and it's going to slow down my car a
little bit but i'm still getting the car
so i'm still being an adult
we're not out of control but i think you
got to label it and release it
okay yeah
that that's what we
i it took me back to a memory from 30
years ago almost you know for me to do
that but that's that's that's a really
good question
and the other thing you got to do is you
have to follow the narrative of we went
we're going from intense when we leave
baby step three to intentional
okay yeah we go from sprinting to
marathon
yeah one through three is a sprint we're
running from the cheetah we're trying to
keep from getting killed we're getting
the mess cleaned up get the emergency
fund in place then three or four five
and six is a marathon we slow down
because it's a longer run we're pacing
ourselves we're keeping the nutrition
the hydration coming we're going to
finish this 13 and a half this 26.2
we're you know 13.1 or 26.2 we're going
to finish here
and we're going to finish it up we got
to have a plan to do it all the way out
and i can't
you know i can't sprint
until i see the tape yeah and if i got a
little left i'll sprint that last little
bit but that's it and so yeah go ahead
and knock that house out go and get that
car bought go ahead and buy that couch
or fix up that kitchen or you budget
those things and you go okay at this
month i'm going to be able to do this
month over here in the future if i label
this and then you label the fun money
and you're released of guilt yeah if you
look down at your budget and you're in
baby step four through six and there's
not fun things on there then you're
doing it wrong that's not the plan the
plan is not just because intense forever
and have no fun because dave said so
they didn't say that you gotta do this
stuff and so put it in the budget and if
even if you have to force yourself and
go we're gonna go on weekend trips we're
gonna have a date night budget look down
to the where there's things you're
excited about as a couple that you look
forward to doing that's in your budget
uh that's gonna help you release some of
this and you guys are doing great you
have more emotional maturity and
financial maturity than most of america
so know that you're not doing anything
wrong by not putting it all towards the
car but it's it's a common struggle me
and my wife struggle with this as we
paid off the house dave because you want
to be gazelle and we wanted to pay it
off so badly that it was always going
well
when you get there and you finish it's
surreal yeah but then there's also
almost like this confusion
because you you do have to she said it
at the early in the call you do have to
switch a gear yeah you got to downshift
from intense to intentional
and then label it and labeling the money
means it has to be spent on that
releases you
to do that and uh early in the budgeting
process you'll you'll experience that
same kind of a thing when you do your
budget the first time and you actually
label this number of dollars is for food
so when you go to the grocery store you
don't have this
angst this knot in your stomach like
when i buy food am i really is the
electricity gonna get cut off
because i i didn't pay the electric bill
no because you got the electric bill
covered in the budget and you've got
this much allocated for food covered in
the budget and so you get this sense of
peace a sense of power when you start
doing the written plan you get on your
every dollar app and you start running
your budget out yeah there's amazing
freedom in that so it's the same thing
though that label and release
label and release release the emotion
around it label it it has to be used for
that whatever you labeled it unless you
come back and reset the whole budget